there's other parts of the economics PhD
program they haven't really changed for
a long time but actually clearly should
be changed and one of the things is we
should have more of an Ethics thing one
one thing that we're behind physics and
some of the other disciplines as far as
I know there's never been a paper in the
economics Journal that's been retracted
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
it is a great thrill to have on today's
guest uh who is a guido in buns I've
learned how to pronounce his name he is
one of our many many Dutch guests who
honor me by coming on and of course you
know Ito that uh the telescope was
invented not by uh Galileo halei as most
people think but actually by of course a
Dutchman Hansen van um uh leprechae and
so he invented that and then another
Huntsman lansman uh by the name of uh
Hans van Leon I think you could
pronounce the name better than me he
invented the microscope so we we will
look into the telescope and look out in
the universe and we will look into your
crystal ball and your microscope later
on this podcast but it's a great Delight
to have you on uh especially since it's
our birthday season you and I are born
the same week of September so happy
belated birthday to you and happy thank
you early bird tomorrow is my birthday
so this is a great treat for me to have
you on the podcast thank you so much so
I'll give you a quick introduction uh
Dutch American Economist at Stanford
University
um he won the most prestigious award in
all of society Humanity the world uh
which I have won too uh called the uh
Horace Mann medal at Brown University
for outstanding graduate student
performance
um uh and then he went on to win another
medal uh called the Nobel Memorial prize
in economic Sciences uh with uh jointly
with Josh uh angrist for their
methodological contributions for the
analysis of causal relationships and it
sounds incredibly complicated and of
course Guido you are the first
non-physics Nobel Prize winner of the 14
Nobel list I've had on you are the first
um so first of all thank you so much for
coming on thanks thanks for having me
always happy to see a their fellow Grand
the university graduates and it was it
was a great pleasure to be there kind of
when I won the Horace Mann medal so it's
it's uh so it's good to see you thanks
yeah it's great to be with you and uh
when I was introduced this past May for
uh by uh Dean Andrew Campbell of The
Graduate School uh he said you know uh
it's very we have 100 correlation
between winners of the Horus man medal
and uh Nobel prizes uh although the
record only lasts for one year uh so you
know as I explained one thing my
audience loves is when we dive deep into
books and uh from your work on inference
and causality uh you'll know that
there's an expression which is never
judge a book by its cover but I claim
what else do you have to go on when you
don't have any other prior information
so I wanted to begin with hearing it
from from you and maybe someday we'll
get your co-author Donald Rubin on your
book which I've begun to read and really
am enjoying it's called causal inference
for statistics social and biomedical
sciences and introduction and it has a
very
um a very uh minimalist cover I would
say but umida could you please explain
the origin of that book the title and
the cover if any uh thoughts that went
into it yeah sure
um I said origin was sort of very clear
that so I was an assistant professor in
the economics department at Harvard at
the time and so don Ruben was in the
statistics Department which is in the
next building in the in the science
center but for for whatever reasons that
was right next to the the building that
had the economics Department
and so that at that time I've been
working with doesn't work with Josh
angrist uh in fact kind of we started
the work for which we we shared the
Nobel Prize coverage we also shared with
David Carr and so it was it was sort of
clear
that there was a connection between the
work we were doing and the the work Don
Ruben had been doing in the in the
statistics uh literature so I I
actually the overlap with Josh Angus
only for one year then he went uh to the
University of Jerusalem there for a
couple of years but I said I decided to
go kind of talk to Don Ruben and see
kind of if we had enough in common kind
of what what's that we could share
because that's always kind of a big
challenge
to start talking with people in other
disciplines it's kind of you know it's
very hard you often have a different
language you you're used to making
particular assumptions that the other
discipline may actually think are very
controversial and people have different
ways of thinking about what the the
relevant problems are so it's kind of a
big challenge but at that time I was
very early in my career I wasn't really
very set in my waist so I was kind of
quite happy to
to talk to Donna and kind of try to
explain how we were thinking about it
and and understand what he was doing and
kind of remarkably because Don was much
more senior at that point but he was
actually very open-minded and he was
kind of you know he was we sort of a
little hot it was a little hard to get
started he was like well you know these
economists I never understand what
they're doing it doesn't really make any
sense to me but I sort of we persisted
for a bit and then then he got very
interested in in what uh what Josh and I
were doing and actually I remember once
uh
getting a call from him and he said well
hey I'm I'm at the airport here in Rome
I said I had a couple of hours and I was
looking at the paper you gave me and you
know I think kind of it's not really
right but there really is something
interesting in here and it's gonna we
should talk more about this we should
yeah
we should talk and kind of figure out
what is really there and then so a
little later we actually
started teaching a course together no
again the Harvard was kind of a very
tricky place to be junior faculty but it
did give me an enormous amount of
Freedom so I went to my chair at the
economics department and said hey I want
to teach this course with someone in the
statistics Department
and the chair said basically said well
whatever I don't really care go go ahead
and uh and do that sir and that was that
was just so that we started teaching
this course on uh on causal inference
okay the funny thing was we you know we
wrote this course description there
and then the registrar's office would
put out this this whole book with all
course descriptions which was that was
not online in those days it was just a
big print uh book The spell checker
replaced every instance of the word
causal by casual so this was a course on
casual inference and we're gonna catch
all this and Casual that sort of my
confused we had a huge turnout the first
day we quickly left when they realized
actually no no it was still going to be
you know it's still going to be math in
there it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't just
at all
[Music]
yeah it was a casualty almost of the
publisher wow uh that is it I mean that
actually you know that that of course
has happened many times when uh when
National Public Radio the announced the
Nobel Prize last year they said that
Josh and I had won for our study of
casual relationships
yeah so economists where they were you
know very uh light t-shirts when they do
uh casual so who is the book for is it
it's a text I mean it's a Cambridge
publication right it's it's uh so that
book really came out of that of course
we're teaching kind of like we were
trying to kind of combine these
perspectives from statistics and
economics uh it was intended for for
students in statistics and in social
science is kind of all the areas where
people in the end are interested in
estimating
then learning about causal effects and
because that's through in all of social
science we don't we don't really care
just about the correlations we see in
the in the data and and how people
behave and and how much people they earn
we want to know what policy makers could
change
and for that to have some effect we want
to know in advance what these effects
are so we want to learn about causal
effects and so it's it's on the greatest
graduate students uh We've taught that
we've taught various verses of these
courses kind of also to policy
institutions uh so it's the it was
intended for for a broad audience to
give people an idea sort of how to think
about causality and and causal effects
and in that you know kind of ins
instance and we'll get into a little bit
more of of your work but um I hear a lot
in the economics literature about all
these revolutions uh you know marginal
Revolution the uh um inflation
Revolution you're credited with uh with
uh something called The credibility
Revolution
um can you uh you and you're in your uh
uh colleague David Carr can you you know
first of all what what are these Rebels
how many revolutions do we need in in a
field uh we we have a Quantum Revolution
every 100 years in physics yeah what is
this such a rep what does it take to
constitute a revolution as I said um
well so so here there's a not a term I I
call it actually just Angus uh coined
that that term
um but the
sort of in the 80s kind of so economics
kind of always has a couple of different
components that's kind of theoretical
work where people do sort of apply
mathematical modeling of uh of economic
behavior and then there's this empirical
work where people actually take models
to the data and try to use them for for
giving policy advice and and and helping
the in decision making
and so there are often there we're very
explicitly interested in in causal
effects and kind of over the years and
that goes back to the early 1900s in
kind of Timber was one of the founders
there he was the the
one of the people who won the first
Nobel prize in economics uh which which
of course was established much later
than the other prizes uh in in 69. and
so
um they started kind of with building
these these economic models and try to
to still get credible causal effects and
uh over the years these models became
much more complex and much much fancier
and so the partly economists got a
little carried away by the by their
clapping us and kind of try to to build
this this really complicated things and
so in the 1980s people became a little
uh disillusioned with that and this is
the famous paper that
sort of cards the angress and I all cite
in our Nobel lectures as kind of as a
source of inspiration
by a guy at UCLA uh at lemur that had
the title let's take the con out of
econometrics so actually I had to give a
guest lecture recently and they said
well you know now he wanted to change
the title to who put the tricks into
econometrics but it was he was he's
incredibly
good right it's actually someone you
should have on on your oh yeah I would
love to have an introduction yeah he's a
very he's a very witty there right and
in his paper at some point he writes you
know the problem with economics is that
nobody really believes the the results
anymore no and or at least nobody
believes anybody else's results and he
shows this empirical some of these
empirical papers where people really
make this this quite outrageous claims
and in a way that kind of it suggests
this somehow think these are relevant
for for policy makers it looks the
particular example he looks at this what
is the deterrence effect of the of the
death penalty and no because that's a
very controversial right and their
political discourse but there's these
people trying to write these papers and
they claim you know for every execution
be safe three lives for people would
would have gotten murdered otherwise you
know other people who write this papers
well for every execution
that leads to five more murders and they
they all claim that they they estimate
these effects with great precision and
it's sort of very clear if you look look
at that the
seriously that these these papers are
really meaningless there's no way you
can learn that from the data this the
assumptions people make are really just
outrageously strong and it just doesn't
make any sense that you could possibly
learn that from uh from that type of
data but and there was a lot of
empirical work of that type where people
were making these strong claims and it
really just
didn't hold up for
and so what what started then in the
late 80s and this is kind of people at
Princeton kind of where both David Carr
Dave Garth was on the the student and on
the faculty there Josh Angus was a
student there and a bunch of people who
started
trying to find ways
of getting sort of being clear when you
could actually get credible results of
the this data satisfying lemurs concern
that not only they would believe that
people would really believe in
themselves but also that you could
convince other people that these results
were actually serious and then that
policymakers should take these these
serious and that that really started the
what angris much later called The
credibility Revolution we kind of tried
to make the empirical work more credible
and not rely on these these very fancy
uh models that yeah may have looked
complicated and that that could maybe
fool other for some people but really
that we're not really very believable
yeah when you uh begin the book you talk
very practically about
um uh issues which almost have an
ethical you know kind of counterpart and
I wondered what's their motivation you
know since the book or maybe uh the book
is so timely for What's called the
reproducibility crisis in the biomedical
Sciences so part of the title is you
know includes biomedical Sciences as one
of the target audiences for causal
inference for statistics so can you talk
about that are we in a reproducibility
crisis and if so is this book and your
work does that have any impact say on
the ethics of of the way that science is
done or is it merely to and importantly
to uh to to Really provide a framework
to assess how one is not thinking
causally properly what what is the
influence on the reproducibility crisis
so economics also has a huge
reproducibility crisis any kind of it's
sort of at a lot of different levels but
including kind of the very mundane level
that people publish papers and they may
even post their data and then if you try
to just even making all the assumptions
the authors make even using their code
it doesn't the numbers don't even come
out the way they are in the the program
so I'm one of my my roles is I'm an
editor of Economics one is one of the
leading journals in economics and there
we're now moving towards having the
papers at least
narrowly reproduced before we publish
them where
some of the economics Journal started it
a couple of years ago but for a long
time there was there was no comment for
a long time people didn't even have to
share the data there wow now economics
in general is moving more towards okay
we we do need to really make sure our
people share that data we need to have
much more transparency and
reproducibility and that's sort of
partly you know we need to train the
students better when I when I was an
undergraduate and even as a graduate
student when we wrote code for
estimating our models that was not
intended for anybody else to use right
just writing for ourselves so I might
put in comments in my code and Dutch or
kind of and and things that were only
comprehensible to me but now of course
that that's no longer acceptable you
work in teams you need to be able to do
it in a way that someone else can use it
and it needs to be have a clear pipeline
where the data comes from how they're
they're used and the
but kind of that so that that's kind of
a very narrow definition of
reproducibility but then more generally
it's sort of clear we need to get much
better at at checking that results that
people find in a particular context work
in other settings external validity of
course is a huge uh issue and that that
ties in very closely with causality
um
experimental data often of course are
great for for internal validity but the
external fluidity is not always so clear
and you see in it in in Social and
policy debates people continue to refer
to experiments that were done on Early
Childhood interventions kind of on early
schooling on the Head Start type
programs with these experiments were
done in the 60s
and got a very small towns in Michigan
and you know it's it's very helpful to
have those experiments but it doesn't
really tell us
what would happen if we did similar type
or Head Start type programs now and in
very different uh locations so we in
clearly in social sciences we need to
worry a lot more about external validity
then you guys have to do in in physics
you know right here although it's it's
hard for we can't easily reproduce you
know a spaceship you know if the James
Webb Space Telescope has some results
and then you say well I won't believe it
until it's reproduced I mean
that could be kind of expensive um even
by NASA standards and and I wanted to
um you know pivot a little bit to your
work as an educator I mean you're a
renowned educator uh phenomenal clear
headed thinker and you know one thing
I've thought about with my students we
don't really have required classes on
ethics
um it's just sort of you know if you if
if you come upon it maybe it's
interesting maybe it's not you'll you'll
study ethics and our colleagues in the
medical school in the law school
even in Business Schools they you know
at least have paid I would say I don't I
don't want to say lip service but way
more than the lip service that I
personally pay I'll just speak for
myself what do you think is the role of
of you know ins you know instantiating a
higher level of credibility via starting
early at the ground level or do you
think it's you know at students teaching
them ethics teaching them
reproducibility metrics best practices
Etc as an educator when what is that is
that a worthy goal if so how do you guys
do it in economic Sciences well I I
think we are there where we're equally
far behind as as physics and so I think
that it is becoming an uh an issue and
it it's something we need to
to deal with and it now
in some sense kind of just looking back
over my whole career there's there's a
number of institutional aspects of the
profession that haven't really changed
in since I since I got into the
profession actually the job market for
economists still works exactly the same
we people apply for jobs in November we
interview people at a meeting Dental
economics meeting in January and then we
fly people out for the for the seminars
and then we offer them jobs and that
there has been exactly the same since
the since sometime in the 70s only
change now the restaurants you take them
to it's only different on on Alma Street
you take them to a different place on
Alma Street then yeah the the
main chain one change and that was
already controversial we moved to
meetings from between Christmas and New
Year to after New Year that took a lot
of the yeah to buy people buy into that
but not and the other change is now two
years ago we started doing the
interviews online
um and suddenly everybody realized
actually you know it's not ideal but it
does mean it's much it levels the
playing field in a way that right having
these interviews be online more people
can attend the interviews it's much
cheaper for everybody and so we're
probably not going back effort to doing
the interview part in person and kind of
the same way there's other parts of the
the the economics PhD program they
haven't really changed for a long time
but actually clearly should be changed
and a lot of the things is we should
have more of an Ethics thing one one
thing that where we're behind physics
and some of the other disciplines as far
as I know there's never been a paper and
economics
Journal that's been retracted that maybe
because we're just Superior beings and
we don't the public their editors are
all great and they we never publish
wrong things but sort of clear that
that's not right it really means we just
haven't had a system where we we're able
to retract papers if if it turns out
they're wrong or they're fraudulent you
know other disciplines have had problems
where people have published
fraudulent papers and it must be the
case that we've done so as well and we
just haven't had a system where where we
do that and now kind of and imagine only
sort of at least explicitly saying when
people submit a paper be aware that we
have the right to retract things out
after publication if if we find that
something was uh was completely wrong
and I think that goes hand in hand with
the fact that we actually needs to to
educate The Graduate students better in
terms of the ethics of the profession it
is there's other aspects of the
profession where
the whole publication process where we
ask people to review things exactly what
the the ethics are is not made very
clear and I actually I know someone at
San Diego Paul Newhouse has of course
kind of on
professional issues kind of about how to
referee papers how to do projects how to
read papers kind of all about how to
function effectively yes and the
profession
and I think we need to have have more of
that that kind of needs to be a part of
the the graduate program really at uh at
every the
PhD granting institution yeah you know
it's not clear exactly how much these
things are disciplined specific whether
we should just have a general yeah
program for for all incoming graduate
students especially since people come in
for very different cultures
actually one one thing that I always
find fascinating yeah
so here at Stanford we have this um and
you may have a San Diego as well we have
the honors code for students that
if I give an exam I can't actually
be in the room where the students take
the exam they they're supposed to to
monitor themselves and
they're supposed to then tell me if
someone else is cheating
and once I was at a at a the party we're
talking about that and we we asked
people if they would actually do that if
they would inform on their fellow
students
if they saw them cheating yeah and all
the Americans said you know yes they
would they would do that the majority
and all the non-americans all the
Europeans said no no they wouldn't do
that they wouldn't inform on on other
students and they feel that as kind of
ratting out your your fellow students
because at some level it's a much better
system to have an honors code so yeah
you should police ourselves rather than
than needing some outside Authority but
given that so many of our graduate
students come from Europe or other
countries
we need to
instill that into students I mean we
need to teach them ethics much more
effectively
given that we really don't do any of
that uh then we do at the moment yeah no
I think it's I think it's you know time
or your your colleague Carl Wyman in
physics at Stanford also Nobel Laureate
we've had him on the podcast and you
know he's talked a lot about how you
know education at least in physics is at
the equivalent level in his opinion to
you know teaching bloodletting and
leeches and so forth in physiology uh
back in uh you know so he's done great
work in kind of flipping the classroom
and other things we also have Eric mazur
scheduled to come on the podcast from
Harvard and not too distant future but
I've always you know wondered yeah I
mean your point about cultural
differences is incredibly significant
there's Rabbi uh Sachs who passed away a
couple years ago now we need to talk
about the differences between guilt
cultures and shame cultures and you know
broadly maybe the US versus Europe and
Asia could be divided along those axes a
kind of internal motivation guilt versus
not wanting to shame somebody in the
European or Asian tradition so
um I think it's fascinating I you know
we're always saying oh we don't have
time and and um you know I wonder you're
so you're so productive and I want to
get to your lecture slides because
they're they're so delightful
um and I know my audience will love it
but what what is your workflow I know
you're you're dedicated you know family
man father
um you're a renowned educator author
teacher what what do you what's your
what's a day in the life of akleto in
men's what does it look like what how do
you accomplish so much
but
um so I don't really
at some level feel myself sort of as
getting getting along look down though
it's I do do try to stay away from the
from the guilt because they're always
there I I I do not like that and I find
it very yeah I'm productive but it um
you know part of it I I just I just love
the work I love working with the
students uh so
you know what I what I do in my day I
spend time with my my family and my kids
them and I I do work and I don't really
do a huge number of other things I had
to go biking here with some colleagues
here living you know you live in San
Diego we're still living here in Palo
Alto biking is just amazing and um and
stuff but I I don't I don't really enjoy
watching TV very much so that I don't
really do you use the mind of that but
even that and no I don't don't know
about you but it's I do sort of have
have self-control problems for a while
during the pandemic I was using uh the
there's this app called Freedom that
kind of oh yeah that doesn't allow you
to to surf the the internet for the
whole screen goes Greener you're now
free to do do the stuff you're supposed
to do right I use that for a while
because I I find myself kind of getting
too too distracted and in the end for me
what's always been
kind of both productive and and
enjoyable it's kind of it's having time
to think and not not be distracted but
it takes it takes a fair amount of
effort for me to get into that state
where I can can really think that you
know I need a couple of hours to really
do that and and be productive and of
course that's over the older I get the
harder it is to find that time to do
that and and not not get distracted
because there's always a lot of a lot of
other things to do but I I try to to
that's kind of the part I'm most
disciplined that I try to find ways of
making sure
even if I'm on the computer to not move
around to different screens and stuff
and uh and not have all these other
windows open that that if I'm stuck that
I would start doing other things and
really to try
to think deeply into to things there
don't ruin my my course on the on the
books that I have this expression that
you know you need to be willing to think
so hard that your head hurts right kind
of really yeah really think deeply and
then when I was a kid I was I was into
playing chess and kind of yeah I was
just going to ask you about that yeah
that felt they were actually felt like
very good exercise
for for what I do now I don't really
play much anymore because apparently
it's not it's it's not very relaxing
but the the ability to kind of really
shut out distractions and focus on on
one problem and kind of just try to make
progress on that
irrespective of how long it takes uh
that uh
I find that a lot of fun and it's uh
even though it's kind of it's
frustrating in the moment when it's you
know making progress but it that's sort
of what I enjoy about one of the things
I really enjoy about the job all right
yeah Isaac Newton reportedly was asked
when he was asked on a podcast in you
know 1764 yeah how do you do what you do
you know similar question to what I just
asked you and he said
um I do what I do by thinking without
ceasing and he would do things like lock
himself in a dark room for three days at
a time I don't want to compare myself to
didn't you no no no
I'll do it yeah the the the starting out
the distraction that is just you know in
that sense I kind of feel fortunate that
when I grew up we
there was this chess culture where it
sort of when I was 15 16 we would kind
of play with regular adult time control
so you would have these five six hour
games and you would do nothing else
there there was be no telephones that we
know talking to other people you would
just focus on a sequence of of problems
uh and the
I still find that a very useful uh skill
I mean of course good at it but I
learned a lot from from yeah I mean one
of the quotes I have here is that you
credited it
um you know with uh uh your passion for
econometrics uh starting that so
um I wonder you know speaking of uh
Isaac Newton I just brought up uh this
will be make sense in a minute but when
I wrote my um uh the first my second
book is called into the impossible which
is interviews with Nobel laureates and I
was uh speaking with Barry barish who
won the 2017 Nobel Prize co-recipient
for discovering gravitational waves with
the ligo experiment and
um I'll ask I asked him some questions
I'll ask you at the end of this
conversation in 20 30 minutes and that
was you know um what advice do you give
to your former self and he said
basically to um to have more confidence
and eventually to get over having the
Imposter syndrome I said what do you
mean get over it in the future like he
was speaking in the future tense and he
said no when you win a Nobel Prize uh
you have uh I got the Imposter syndrome
worse than any other time in my life
because when you win it apparently you
know I'll probably never find out you
could tell me if this is true but at
least for him he had to sign this this
Ledger that attested to the fact that he
received his medal and his and his share
of the prize money and um and he is a
curious guy so he looked well who signed
this you know 50 years ago and he saw
Feynman and he saw you know uh he saw
Chandra secar and and then he saw uh of
course this guy Albert Einstein and he
said I'm not worthy of Albert Einstein I
cannot be in the same book I'm just a
guy from Oklahoma you know I don't
belong in this book and um I said Barry
guess what you know Albert Einstein had
the Imposter syndrome when it came to
Isaac Newton he thought Isaac Newton did
more than any other human being
effectively since Jesus Christ who was
Isaac Newton's biggest hero so I want to
ask you you know on a personal level
when you achieve this this great height
and I'm not speaking about the horrors
man medal which of course you know the
only medal we'll ever share together but
um does it impact you like uh on a you
know human level it's got to affect you
but does it um how does it affect you
not in terms of um you know my next
paper has to be a really good one but in
terms of meaning and issues of of you
know how you spend your time and and how
you view yourself in the grand kind of
scope of History does it affect you I
mean not not everyone's the same as
barrier or you know suffers from certain
uh you know feelings of inadequacy but
but did it instead maybe Inspire can it
do that um how did it affect you on a
personal level yeah you know and I I
suddenly nah
I try to to push that away but I'm I
certainly suffered from the The
Impossible a center at uh various times
some of them very recently that you know
I went to to brother so economics
compared to uh physics I think it's kind
of much more hierarchical where there's
there's a number of of because it's it's
very cheap for economists to move around
so you end up having the top economists
concentrated at a very small set of uh
universities
and so so going from Brown
to my first stop at uh at Harvard was
was something unusual I'm not sure I
don't think they'd ever hired someone
from from brown brown University before
and so at some point I remember one of
the the senior faculty
saying and this was in reference to to
someone else who'd been hired from a
similarly ranked University as brown and
said well you know we don't always we
don't very often higher from the
provinces
at least the same providences he might
even take Providence yeah yeah exactly
but so that didn't really really help
much with the Imposter the syndrome and
so so the but you know and growing up in
Holland Harvard was a place that I'd
heard of that's probably the only
American Universe I've heard of at the
time
so so when I was there I never really
had the the
feeling I I uh belonged I didn't really
have the expectation of getting Tanya I
didn't get tenure there but and that
didn't really bother me because then
that that was never really on on my
Horizon but I I had a great time there
because I I connected with some people
including angress including improving
including uh a senior colleague in the
economics Department Gary Chamberlain
and so it was a it was a great time for
me
to to learn a lot of things at the same
time I remember sort of going to the the
samurai in my area and economics and
there were there were four senior people
there
and I was incredibly intimidating yeah
so you know partly there some of them
weren't particularly supportive of of
the junior people they they
were very senior they sort of they had
won many prizes
themselves they they
saw themselves that's kind of doing
having done very important work and
doing very important relative to what
what angris and I were were doing uh at
the time and then you know some of them
sort of made it clear that they felt
much more highly of their own work than
they thought of ours you know I suppose
it wasn't really quite clear whether
they were they were rights but it was it
was kind of a tough part it was a tough
environment that I
I suddenly tried to do things
a little differently with with my
students now I think that was not really
a very
supportive environment for for junior
people and yeah I think that was
probably not uh not great
there were parts of it there were there
were great you know some people were
incredibly their support I mentioned
Gary Chamberlain before kind of there
but it the
that that certainly you know it
certainly didn't make me feel like there
was sort of a natural place for me there
was there was a place that that I
belonged but then kind of over the years
um
sort of and even at the time I felt the
work I was doing was good and I got a
lot of of satisfaction out of uh out of
doing doing the work and I enjoyed doing
that so it didn't really
bother me I was I wasn't looking that
much for for
outside validation and it certainly
didn't have any Grand Ambitions uh that
this this would would be work that would
really meet with widespread acceptance
but I thought it was interesting and I
thought it was was good and I got a
sufficient amount of positive feedback
that other people thought it was
interesting and uh and importance and
and novel answer so that that helped me
now they kind of continue to inspire me
to keep doing it uh
yeah well I think you know the the
sometimes it said the opposite of the uh
imposter syndrome is the dunning-kruger
effect where you have a little bit of
knowledge uh and then that makes you
feel like you have this expansive
perspective on the field I always joke I
I have the most knowledge of anybody
about the dunning-kruger effect
um but you know it's sometimes said and
ingest that you know economists have
predicted you know nine out of the last
five uh recessions I I can't resist
asking you you know I don't know how
many podcasts you listen to but nowadays
if I talk to an economist I have to ask
him or her about recession and
blockchain so I beg your Indulgence but
first
um what are your thoughts on recession
are we in the U.S at least in the last
maybe uh headed for one or are you more
optimistic um uh that we can yeah you
know that that's really that so a lot of
things when I run the Nobel Prize in a
lot of my colleagues at Stanford with
Mom before I see you know people are
going to ask a lot of questions about
things you don't really know and I I
yeah I remember kind of earlier when I
was there
when a colleague of mine in any
kinematics won the prize and then there
at a dinner he was talking about that
he'd gone to Korea and it had dinner
with the Finance Minister there
I mean we said well what did you talk
about they said well I talked about
monetary policy and and stuff and he
said well we said but what do you know
about it you're an econometrician there
and he said no you know I I I could talk
about those things uh and so I try to
avoid I'll tell you that I don't really
I'm I'm Not Really Gonna Know much more
than you do about the yeah
who's an economist who's a much more
General
and very prominent of The Economist
would it's very knowledgeable of both
blockchain and so we know more about
recessions uh too but so I I no that's
not yeah I guess the only thing that I
thought might appeal to you about
blockchain is that the ability to have
um very rapid very reproducible
experimentation on the blockchain so um
as a way of of doing what you do so so
well which is you know these kind of
Duncan you know these very rapid and
very reproducible and I wonder if things
like uh if people look into things like
well Universal basic income is something
that people talk about it seems like
that could be something that would be
very amenable to a blockchain you know
deposit into you know I'll give you my
crypto wallet later but but our a kind
of mattress matricians are they looking
at you know possible applications for
blockchain or because most of them that
I've talked to I mean Paul Krugman I
mean I haven't talked to Paul Kruger but
but they're very dismissive of it I mean
your fellow laureates and so forth but
um are there people in the field that
are taking it seriously I've thought
about it for science but but yeah yeah
so all I know really is from uh talking
to my wife who knows much more about
this and so I think there clearly are
real
possibilities and there's real things
possible
through uh Brock saying that that we're
not not possible before so it's clearly
yeah to to stay exactly what form is
going to take I don't know and so it's
not an area I've really thought very
deeply about it you know that that at
some level there was sort of a conscious
decision so that I
and no nowadays in economics people
actually move around much more than than
they used to but I've had a remarkable
remarkable at some level remarkably
narrow career but in Holland I started
doing economics because I was actually
an undergraduate major you can uh choose
I chose that while I was in high school
not really knowing what that was going
to be like
and I I've stayed there ever since the
field has changed but I I've could have
you know I've badly been been good at it
by doing it for a long time longer than
anybody else by this at this point so
that
well uh that's that's great yeah it's
great to to know one's um you know
strength in their character so well that
you can be so focused and that's
probably attributing to a lot of your
success I wonder if we could go over
some of your slides from uh from the
lecture so if you want to take over
screen sharing I think you should have
permission let me first kind of just
talk you briefly through how I got uh
here so I was born in the Netherlands so
I went to high school
and there
at that point actually
um I wasn't really quite sure what I
want to do I was leaning towards physics
or mathematics uh but my older brother
was already studying that so I I
excited I want to do something a little
different and my economics teacher that
gave me this book by Tim Bergen that got
me interested in them in econometrics
and so then I ended up the going to the
university in Rotterdam where they had
they had a special economics program
that was actually set up by timber in
the one of the first Nobel laureates in
in economics but actually the
that go that's that worked out
incredibly well I really enjoyed it and
then at some point
they had an exchange program with the
English University and so not thinking
that through particularly well I ended
up spending uh two years at the
University of uh of Hull and uh in the
north of England
then again by accident the there was a
professor there who was about to take a
job at Brown University in the in the US
and he asked me if I was interested in
uh in going there and doing a PhD at
that point I was was planning to just go
back to Rotterdam and finish my degree
there but going to the US seemed
interesting the challenge so I I
yeah went there so did my PhD at uh at
Brown University greatly enjoyed it
there then I was again thinking about
actually going back to the Netherlands
and taking a position there but I got a
job offer as an assistant professor at
Harvard and again that seemed the
opportunity to Goods to uh pass up at
the time
so I went there
then
after that I moved to UCLA then and then
to Berkeley then actually back to
Harvard uh instead of time my wife was
at Stanford and we're trying to figure
out where we which place would work for
for both of us so we went back to
Harvard but then 10 years ago we moved
back to the West Coast to uh Stanford
where we've been ever since
so kind of what what is my research
about
kind of the the general theme is it's
about the causality yeah it's kind of
the obviously we we all know that
correlation isn't in general the the
same as causality but then the question
is how do you actually get cause or
facts because there's social science as
well as in biomedical Sciences typically
what uh what we're interested in is
causal facts you want to know what would
happen if we changed something what
would be the cause of effect of some
policy or companies may want to change
the way they do business the way they
they approach customers or the way they
present options to customers we all want
to know what would actually happen if we
we change something in the environment
or changed some of these things and so
all of my research is about how to to do
that in a credible way and sometimes we
can do randomized experiments like we do
in drug trials but in many cases we
can't we can't really do experiments
to decide whether education is a good
thing or a bad thing we can't prevent
people from going to college and force
others to go to college just to learn
what the effect is so we need to do
clever things with the data to figure
out what uh what the causal effects are
there
and that is kind of where where most of
my research is and the the Nobel Prize
was sort of partly for the
the work trying to figure out the to
exploit natural experiments to exploit
situations whether some random variation
that can help us learn about cause or
effects in the absence of uh of formal
randomization
and so kind of the just again to stress
the point that that correlation is is
not causality it's kind of many cases
where we see
simple correlations uh the the rooster
crowing is very highly correlated with
the Sun rising
shark attacks are very highly uh
correlated with ice cream sales but it's
clear that in both cases there's no
causal effects uh going from one to the
other ice cream sales don't cost shock
it that you may be correlated because in
the summer people go swimming and are
more likely to get attacked by sharks at
the same time they're more likely to get
its uh ice cream here in this daily
actually there's a real data you see
that this correlation is actually
negative that's because it's uh shark
attacks in Australia and ice cream sales
in Florida so when it's summer here
people go swimming in
Florida and also it go buy ice cream in
Florida but at the same time there's few
people there swimming at that time in uh
in Australia so there's a few shark
attacks
but so given that the
correlation is not the same as uh
causality what do we really mean by
causality and this is where I was very
heavily influenced by some of the work
uh don Ruben had done in in statistics
uh and he kind of feuded us
all about thinking about it some
manipulations thinking about some action
you can take so here on the slide is
this poem part of a poem by Robert Frost
the two roads diverged in a yellow wood
and sorry I could not travel both and be
one traveler long I stood and looked
down one as far as I could to where it
Bend in the undergrowth and I sort of
really
there illustrates well that there's the
problem we want to think about causal
effects as there being some decision
point where you could go left or right
and because of fact is is the outcome
abundant of the road first the the
outcome at the other hand at the end of
the other road but you can't really ever
see both because you can only take one
of the roads you want to so you want to
think about a cause of fact
as
not a the effect in the abstract sense
the effect of a particular manipulation
of a particular action I can go to
college or not go to college I can take
an aspirin or not take an aspirin
or you can send people some information
or not send them that information this
is the general notion of counter
factuality right exactly so you can take
one of these actions and see what
happens there you can take the aspirin
and maybe your headache will go away but
you'll never know for sure
where I would have gone away had you not
taking the aspirin right and so you can
never directly observe any of the the
causal effects and that's kind of the
the big uh challenge yeah
and so kind of to deal with that to be
want to think about what the
manipulation is we're going to need
clearly neat multiple units multiple
people multiple objects uh so we can see
some that are exposed to the to the
treatment as some that are that are not
exposed to the treatments uh
and we want to think about why they
actually got the treatments they got was
it chance or was it choice and that's
kind of really uh important thing here
because there's there's really
actually let me skip a couple of slides
because we're there that's really where
the statistical traditions and the the
social science traditions diverged and
where to some extent the work with Ruben
and with angriest part of the book with
Ruben kind of brings back brings
together these these Traditions again
but in statistics the
study of course of facts was really in
the context of randomized experiments
where we just really very sure we get
what we we want we take a set of
individuals or some population we split
them into two groups we give some of
them bomb treatment and some of them
another treatment and because we
actually randomize as Fisher and kind of
stressed if you actually do the physical
randomization we know that even if these
groups are different the chances that
they're very different is is controlled
I mean we can we can put Precision on
how how different these populations
could be and so we we end up with very
credible estimates of course in fact
that's of course why the Food and Drug
Administration insists for new
treatments that we actually do randomize
experiments they don't want to just have
to drag companies say hey some people
took it and they're doing great and some
people didn't take it and they're not
doing so well we want to make sure that
we can we can come control the the error
rates there they'll be confident that we
get a cause or fat but in in
and I mean
in economics that that didn't really
work sometimes it works and in fact the
Nobel Prize in 2019 went to the
tree of economists would started doing
experiments in there in economics and
that's been very effective in some
settings but sort of clear that we can't
do that in in many
cases we can't force people to go to
school and and prohibit others from
going to school just so we can learn
with a high degree of credibility what
uh what the cause or fact of uh of
schooling is I've often thought that I'm
sorry to interrupt but you know one of
them when I was a graduate student at
Brown we had I had a fellowship required
me to go and teach in public schools in
Providence and I remember teaching them
back then this is in the mid 90s late
night you know early 90s and um I was
teaching these students and um I taught
I was teaching you know how many planets
there are et cetera et cetera and I said
I just thought to myself if I come back
30 years from now and I say there I ask
these adults you know who are children
in the early 90s how many planets are
there
um you know and if they say eight you
know whatever I was teaching them back
then it could have been nine actually
but anyway they say eight I'll have no
idea if I had any educational impact
putt if I teach them that there's 427
planets then then if at least if I come
back 30 years later and say you know how
many planets are and they say 437 27 at
least I'll know I made an impact and you
know a lot of my colleagues looked at me
in horror but uh but yeah these These
are the types of experiments that would
be great to you know see if we can do
numerically or you know a blockchain I
don't know um the airdrop money into
people's block uh you know wallets
um but uh that's that's it is it is
fascinating yeah though the type of so
in the end kind of very early on the
economists kind of decided in a lot of
cases we couldn't really do experiments
yeah and actually the the starting point
wasn't even cases where you could and
face in doing the experiments but where
it's even hard to see what what the
experiment would uh would be like so
Timber again kind of in the 1920s was
interested in in estimating the demand
for particular product so for for
hauling in those days you know if you've
ever seen the
the Dutch paintings of Van Gogh kind of
foreign
in those days
and so he wanted to to know what the
effect was of
the price on the demand for potato flour
and you kind of as economists and this
is actually kind of entering interesting
where
you know from a computer science
perspective when I talked to my friends
Sarah from a statistics perspective
they're like wow the effect could be
positive or negative actually economists
are pretty sure that prices go up yeah
it's going to go down but we don't know
how much yes we don't want to Simply
and that that's really a kind of a
fundamental
inside there from from economics way
back we we don't want to just look at at
quantities where prices are high and
where prices are low I say well their
difference tells us what the difference
is in demand because prices are not set
randomly it's not like an experiment the
prices are set
by sellers because they they think
that's what the market can bear that's
what they can get away with and so when
they see that the demand is high they go
to charge more
and so disentangling
how the prices are set what the supply
is and what the demand is is kind of a
key challenge here and that's the just
from from looking at prices and
quantities you can't really do that and
so so part of what the economists have
been been doing from the since the 1920s
is kind of trying in so those settings
to disentangle these different forces
and estimate what the effect of of
prices on demand or the effect of prices
on on suppliers and that's I'll come
back to that kind of what you would do
in in this particular situation kind of
with this demand and Supply settings but
what kind of and at a general level they
they did was they tried to to build a
model for how people behave in these
markets
and then try to use that to disentangle
these two forces kind of supply and uh
and demand and kind of uh essentially
what what the solution is going to be is
to find something
that affects Supply
without affecting demand something
that's going to supply shift the supply
function and but not change the demand
function that's going to help you that's
what we what what is called an
instrument and that's going to help you
figure out what the demand is now and
instead of one of the papers
then I did with the with Josh angris and
um another co-author of ours Katie ready
is we looked at it and sat in the filter
Fish Market this is this was day that I
actually Katie had collected for her her
thesis
for on the on the price and quantity of
a particular type of fish sold at the
Fulton Fish markets uh Whiting
and so
so to get to see what's the estimated
demand function so the question was what
is what is there that changed this
Supply
but doesn't change how much people are
going to demand at a particular price
now can I there may be a
strange question and so
that's not an easy question to to answer
directly but kind of for me economics
perspect it sort of very clear as he
came up with a very nice solution there
she looked at weather conditions at sea
things like wave height so if if if
there's a lot of waves if it's very
choppy it's just going to be hard for
people to catch the fish
more dangerous out there it's gonna you
know if it's stormy there's not going to
bring as much fish
the onshore because if I'm interested in
buying fish if I'm a buyer there I don't
really care what the weather was at Sea
right all I care about is what the price
is yeah how it translates to price and
so that's something that doesn't change
the demand function
but it's going to create variation in
the price because it made made it harder
to catch the fishing so it's going to
change Supply it affects supply side
yeah so that's kind of the way the
economists kind of look for variation in
some part of the model
that doesn't affect other parts of the
of the model so we're very confident
that when I interested in buying the
fish I don't really care about what the
the weather is let's see whether it was
hard for the The Freshman or easy for
the first treatment all I care about is
what are they charging me per pound yeah
and that timbergent is very interesting
he has a uh he have he studied physics
apparently yes at Leiden uh with Paul
Aaron Fest and he uh apparently met many
famous uh physicists like Cameron Annes
uh who won the Nobel Prize for
superconductivity uh and uh and a man by
the name of Albert Einstein and he
actually he may be his son but there's a
famous
um radio astronomer he's passed away now
named Yap j-a-a-p how do you pronounce
that yup yup yeah so he's a very famous
and he actually wrote the canonical
um very slim monograph in my field of
astronomical polar imagery so what a
family and his brother won the Nobel
Prize I was going to say that that
that's amazing he's he's a a hero family
yeah it was a very remarkable guy and
and so you know we talked a little
earlier kind of about what things to do
beyond the academics but he was a big
Institution bill that he built some of
the government's advisory institutions
he built he started a
degree program in econometrics in in
Holland he did a lot of stuff for the
United Nations
during the
Hungarian Hungarian Uprising in the 50s
he actually took in Refugee children
from from Hungary in his in his house he
was just a remarkable unbelievable being
scholar and an intellect I mean yeah he
was just a very very remarkable person
and sort of
interesting kind of no that his work
inspired me when I was in high school
but I it was only much later that I read
the his work but it's it still resonates
preferably still has a very modern feel
to it I was fortunate enough that when I
was a student in Rotterdam I actually
did go to a public lecture he gave there
he was still coming there occasionally
so that I do feel this this intellectual
kinship uh
with with him
so
but sort of later the economists kind of
started building these more and more
complex models and so here here's a very
interesting
the slide to the the picture on the
right is a picture of this uh
of a economic model but a physical
version of a economic model so when I
was an undergraduate in Rotterdam they
would actually bring this out kind of
once a year so it was a model where
water flows
their models the flow of money in the in
the economy so they're kind of were all
these the basins in this machine kind of
that
showed the GDP and then there were
lavros that you could pull to change
interest rates to have a monetary policy
to have a fiscal policy to change
exchange rates uh and it sort of it was
a very it was a physical model that
allowed you to to simulate how the
economy would respond to various
government policies
and it kind of you know and it's a very
complicated model here yeah and it could
do many remarkable things but it also
symbolize kind of how the how complex
these models became over the years and
at the same time time
how they became less and less credible
over the years so when I when I was an
undergraduate there they would wheel
this out and then they would demonstrate
the model and it wasn't working anymore
whatever you would do the water would
leak out of the machine and would all
would end up on the on the floor and and
GDP would very quickly be down to uh to
zero so it's there it symbolized kind of
the state of uh of economic econometrics
kind of over the years in in one and uh
than one way
and then kind of by the the
80s there was this paper by Lima that I
mentioned before let's take the calm out
of Economics where he really took issue
with the fact that that very little of
the empirical work
was uh was credible was believable and
that that it was losing influence uh as
a result because you know whatever
policy people there were supporting they
could find some work that that showed
that I was a great uh
idea and someone else could find the
opposite paper that that would propose
the opposite and provide support for
that
and kind of when when Angus and I came
into the the profession
there was a real sense that a lot of the
empirical work was just not credible and
and what we were trying to do
was find find ways of of improving that
find the ways where people could
actually do empirical work
that was believable not just to them but
that was believable for others that that
was useful for policy maker so that that
was robust to kind of a lot of the the
auxiliary assumptions people were
putting in their models uh that made
assumptions that you could actually talk
about that were transparent and that you
could where you could build support for
the results in the incredible ways
and of course that's not always possible
kind of you know Lima and look at this
analysis of the deterrence effect for
the death penalty and there at some
level you just cannot do it there's no
data available in the US that would
really tell you one way or the other
what's uh what the effects are there and
so it it also kind of forces us to be a
little bit more humble and acknowledge
that sometimes we're not going to be
able to give credible uh answers but in
in some cases we do
so let me
um I don't know how much time we still
will still have oh it's up to you uh I'm
I'm happy to go as long as uh okay so
let me go so this is kind of one of the
the key examples
that was cited in the the awards so let
me go through some detail here so
when uh when Josh Angus wanted his
thesis he looked at uh he was interested
in the effect of estimating uh
the effect of serving in the military on
the earnings and so this is kind of one
of these cases where obviously we can't
do a randomized experiment or no
randomized experiment have been done and
you're worried that people who serve in
the military are different for people
who don't serve in the military in lots
of different ways they may be more less
risk of Earth they may have their more
skills they may be more Highly Educated
they may be different in many uh many
ways so how are we ever going to find
comparisons that people would actually
find believable
and so the
first step was to uh
the
go back to the Vietnam War when there
was a military draft and kind of
realized that because the way the the
draft was implemented through a lottery
that we get two groups that are
comparable just like in a randomized
experiment the people were we had low
lottery numbers who got drafted who were
draft eligible were exactly exactly the
same as the people who didn't get
drafted we had a high lottery number
to that it's just like a randomized
experiment the these groups are not
identical but a comparable example
because of the the randomization problem
was that not everybody who was drafted
served in the military and not everybody
was not drafted didn't serve in the
military in fact if you kind of look at
the
the numbers there actually let me skip a
couple of uh
slides here if you look at the
the the number of the percentage of
people was drafted were actually served
it's about 31
but 19 of the people who didn't uh get
drafted served in the military so it
these things weren't perfectly
correlated and so the question is kind
of how how can we
make progress there and
the starting point then was to think
about the
this the people were not drafted and
thinking of there being three types of
people there's some people who are
always going to serve in the military
were going to volunteer and you know for
them getting a high lottery number or a
low lottery number didn't really matter
they were they were they were happy to
to go serve in the military yeah
the exact value of the lottery number
didn't uh didn't matter
then there was another group where
who wasn't going to serve in the
military irrespective of of their lotto
number they might have had a medical
condition they might have had bones
first there whatever again having a high
lottery number or a low lottery number
does it doesn't really matter for that
but then there's this group in the
middle
this is what we call the the compliance
they kind of actually do what the draft
was intended to do they get drafted they
serve they don't get drafted they didn't
serve
they weren't actually going to volunteer
but they were willing to to submit to
the draft if they if they get drafted
and so the the
so if if they were not drafted they
would end up as in the civilian labor
force but if if they if they did
actually get drafted then they would
Swiss and they would serve in the
military and you can't kind of see that
really what you would like to do is kind
of know who these compliers are because
them for that group you actually do have
a randomized experiment
there the randomization does exactly
what it what it's supposed to do it
switches people from the compli from the
not serving to the serving uh the
population but the problem is we can't
tell we can't tell directly who this uh
who these people are we can we can
partition the the population kind of
into these four groups but whether they
were drafted or not and whether they
actually served or not
but you can't tell
whether someone is a complier because if
you see that someone was not drafted and
didn't serve they could be they it could
be degenerated right
it could be that they would never serve
or that their complier and so the the
question is how do we disentangle this
uh these these groups and that's kind of
where the
the
Insight was that if we're willing to to
we kind of we're trying to disentangle
these these groups but from the from
seeing draft status and federal says we
can already first of all we can estimate
the fraction of this uh this three types
okay and here we find that the fact
about the 20 percent were volunteers
about 70 percent would never have served
in the military and then there's only
this this 12 percent within this
compliance group we're actually the the
one we're most interested in they would
serve if they got drafted but not if
they didn't get drafted and we still
can't tell exactly who they are we could
tell how many there are but we can't
tell which individuals there there are
then the the
The Next Step was to uh
to soon
that for these guys who sir were always
served and would never serve the draft
just really doesn't matter it didn't
affect their outcomes now that's kind of
still
a tricky or something because it may
work very well if these people were
exempt for medical reasons
but it may not work so well if they make
choices to get out of military service
if they would
move to Canada or they would do other
things to stay out of military service
but if we are willing to make that that
assumption then we can estimate what the
effect is for of military service for
this group in the middle for this 12 of
the the compliance and and kind of for
the data that that Angus collected
he estimated that it was about a 20
percent decrease in earnings these
people actually paid a huge tax
later in life in terms of their their
earnings
the
by by serving in the military where
their counterparts we had a lottery
number that meant they didn't have to
get uh they have to do military service
at earnings that were much higher
because they had additional time in the
the labor market they had additional
experience and they they ended up with
the with better paying jobs and so this
is the kind of the
natural experiment where the
system the structure helped us by
getting giving some credible the
randomization for some part of the
problem and then we combined that with
some of the economic modeling to
disentangle this uh these effects in a
in a credible way
now here kind of just as a as a way sort
of how they may work in other settings
similarly when I grew up we had military
services in the in the Netherlands of
course that was a little different uh
Holland wasn't actually at War at the
time
um an effect they
didn't need as many recruits as they
they were getting so
the um the relative kind of had a
problem that in fact they had too many
people were surfing in the military
um
and so they decided
to deal with that by just exempting one
year entirely so there was one lucky
birthday in 1959 where people didn't
have to serve in the military and the
years before and afterwards everybody in
principle had to serve at about 45 or so
on average did serve in the military
there were still people who had medical
exemptions there were still people who
had religious objections and other
things but typically about 45 or so
served in the military but then there
was this one year when nobody served
and so what you see then much later can
I hear we looked at earnings in in 1990
when these people were in the middle of
their their careers much after their
military service we see that the group
in the middle
this 1959 Birth Cohort actually made
made a considerably more money
than the people born in 58 or the people
born in 1960. and you see that it you
know this is based on their National
Data so it's a live sample even for a
small country it's the the Netherlands
you see that these people just make made
significantly more money
and so that seems very plausible that it
comes from uh from not having to serve
in the military in fact kind of the
numbers are they're not as high as the
Angus the case but it's about four
percent these people make about four
percent
and to kind of make that even more
credible if you do the same exercise for
women who did who never had military
services in the in the Netherlands
for the women there was no no such
difference the 59 cohort was no
different from the the 58 or 60 cohorts
uh and so then additional credibility to
these uh these estimates and so that
that kind of satisfies the Lemur
concerned that you want to make these
things
they're incredible you want to make you
want to find
come up with estimates where you you're
really willing to to put your reputation
on the line that these actually are
incredible causal effects uh
I said let me
go to one more example and so this goes
back to the the
timber and Sally so so here's what this
data actually look like from the filter
Fish Market uh study yeah
that Katie collected these data first he
said that was actually just a remarkable
uh
the thing what she did there because she
would have to get up at two in the
morning every morning and Princeton to
drive over to the to Manhattan to the
filter fish market and you know that was
it there that was a tough place to
collect data there was yeah there were
concerns there
still with organized crime involvement
they got the building
where they kept the records burned down
and it was it was I've been there once
kind of just to see what it was like and
it was not a very pleasant place to
collect data to do a thesis yeah to
collect thesis every day every
transaction just follow the seller
around oh yeah for the transaction and
kind of uh how much fish they sold what
price they sold it and they're kind of
lots of interesting uh things that came
out of that but so here just kind of
looking at
and it's this cloud of data points you
know sometimes prices are high sometimes
prices are low sometimes quantities are
high sometimes quantities are low
correlation is pretty much zero yeah
nothing yeah there
but then what what she did was say well
you know first the first thing that the
economists would do they say well what
do these points really mean we want to
think of every point there as the
intersection of a supply and demand
function
now that doesn't really help very much
there on its own because both supply and
demand clearly change every day in the
this market so that doesn't help us kind
of figure out what is uh what is what
but then what's what she did was collect
data
on what the weather was like at sea in
the day before maybe specimen were
actually out there there
they're catching the fish and so see
defined kind of three sets of days at
least it's going to be here we're using
three sets of days stormy
fine and intermediate
and so stormy was when the waves were
High when the wind was strong there and
what you see is on those days
the prices are relatively High
and the quantities are relatively low
and we think of that as those days
Supply was low
demand wasn't really effective because
nobody kept this the buyers don't really
care they don't care about it his story
let's see what they care like how much
what the price is
like and so then if you look on Fair
Days
the price is relatively low the quantity
is relatively high and so kind of if you
then put this two together that helps
you figure out
what the the demand function is it helps
you disentangle
the supply and demand kind of very much
in the same way that Tim Bergen did with
his uh his potato flower data right in a
you know not in a big data setting in
the setting I think he had like eight
observations uh but it sort of helps you
disentangle these things the same way
the draft lottery creates this random
variation in whether people serve or not
at least for the compliers here the
weather creates this random variation in
the supply function that allows you to
learn about the demand function and
that's you know then the sort of more
complicated stuff in the background
where you want to deal with the fact
that it's actually also hydrogen ID and
the demand function and it may not be
linear but it it's the having this
instrument having this variation in the
supply that helps you trace out what the
what the demand function is and it gives
you more credible estimates of what of
how demand will change if you change the
change crisis and just the vocabulary
the price elasticity is the derivative
of quantity log quantity versus low
prices
which means anti-correlated high quality
quantities yeah so and the minus one is
actually very important because if it
was you know obviously it should be
negative yeah Isis go up demands you go
down but if it's between zero and minus
one it actually means that you would
sell you would
your Revenue would go up if you increase
prices
and so then Salah should should just be
increasing their prices because they
would actually increase their revenue
with and the fact that it would sell
less wouldn't matter because right the
revenue would go out so you would expect
in these markets the the elasticity be
elasticity to be minus one or or less
so that that's and again the raw
correlation between prices and
quantities here is actually pretty much
zero so it's it really shows that this
this is uh
they're making some uh some sense
now kind of the the
last example
is from a paper actually I did with Don
Ruben in a soon enough hours Bruce
sassador and they came directly out of
this first course we were the
we were teaching on on causality very
interesting what the effect was on the
universal basic income initially
actually we're interested in what the
effect was of child poverty here and
there should have been a lot of work on
that and essentially all the empirical
work was just comparing kids in Rich
families with kids and poor families
this you know you need to have kids who
grow up in Rich environments versus
versus poor and sort of clear
it's not really clear what that means
because rich and poor families are
different in lots of different ways
partly their parents have made choices
that parents may have different that may
be different in many ways
it it's not clear that any that
comparison of that is really going to
give you directly the cause of effects
you're interested in because the the
government's not going to take kids from
poor families and put them in in Rich
families all they could ever hold
through is give these families more more
money
and so you want to analyze data that
mimic that type of of thought experiment
and so we'll we'll came out of this
discussion is that it would be very
helpful to look at at
people who played the lottery and who'd
won the lottery there that actually
mimics very closely just giving getting
a guaranteed
stream of income and it's a particular
nice the nice thing about the lottery
there that we we went to in
Massachusetts but that's sort of true in
general
it's that's too often for these
lotteries they don't give you a lump sum
so you win half a million dollars say
you don't get a check for for 500 000
you get a check for twenty five thousand
dollars for the next 20 years and so it
really is like a a universal uh basic
income no it's not quite the same it's
not coming from the government and your
neighbors May realize you won the
lottery anime you know there may be some
pressure on you to do things but that
may be after a couple of years that may
wear off and it may be very much like
you now have this this extra income for
a while I I can't resist asking you you
know if you had the opportunity to take
your Nobel winnings
lump sum which I assume you did uh
versus paid out which which makes more
sense
um you know for give us I think so the
um
I think for these responders at some
level it makes a lot of sense getting it
in over the years because I think yes
when you see there there's often people
don't quite know what to make of it very
early on there and so they they may
waste a lot of it early on but then
after a while they figure out that you
know this is not going to go
on forever I need to actually
make a plan here and what you see in the
in the data as well as you know a lot of
people don't do crazy things with it
they they don't stop working they don't
just waste it all people actually save
save a reasonable uh amount now because
for the the with the Nobel Prize you
know the the thing is it typically goes
to people who are fairly well off
already so it's it's not really clear
that it changes
their life they're quite as uh as
dramatically
as um do you think there's a limit often
and you kind of alluded to this earlier
that you know you really didn't do the
work to win a Nobel Prize you didn't is
there a limit
is there an amount of money I mean there
are prizes worth more than the Nobel
Prize you know the Breakthrough prize is
is worth three or four times is there is
there a point you think that people
would start getting influenced by uh uh
by the you know Financial remuner rate
or is it uh is it is it the demand is is
completely in a lot uh inelastic
because our jobs
all of all of us your job our job my job
they're we're incredibly fortunate we we
get so much freedom to to yes look at
questions that we're interested in there
and so do you wanna you want your life
to be uh to have some meaning and so I
yeah it's sort of you know I guess part
of the problem with academics is often
that we can't get people to to ever
retire because right like like the you
know they like their their jobs uh
they're incredible you get to talk to
really smart people all the time and you
get them to listen to you you get to
hear their ideas uh so it's not quite
clear that you get to travel to
interesting places so it's not really
clear what the what you what I would
really want to uh
to change in that uh no oh yeah fair
enough fair enough I'm I'm more venal
and driven by by these issues than most
but um anyway sorry
I think the aspect of the Nobel Prize
that there's sort of changed since most
for me it's the fact that now it's even
easier to to
reach out to say to some place call some
place say hey what I'm I'm gonna be
passing through that I'd love to give a
talk and everybody's immediately happy
to uh to accommodate that uh and so it
it makes my life
considerably easier and you know it
wasn't difficult to begin with but it
just gives me a huge amount of freedom
to do exactly the the type of research I
want to do and and go listen to the
people I want to listen to I talk to the
people I want to talk to uh
yeah no I I imagine I I guess one
serious question would be
um you know a lot of Nobel laureates and
I'm only using them as a proxy for you
know uh highly accomplished
scientifically
um you know literate and um and capable
people and even restricting the the pool
of data to just experimental physicists
who have won the Nobel Prize eliminating
all the theories you look at them and
almost uniformly I mean none of them
died completely poor maybe you know like
a popper but but many died you know
these are people that invented you know
like Shockley the transistor you know uh
who was up at Stanford right um uh
they're people that invented the laser
Charlie Towns at Berkeley
um they never really received any of the
you know Financial benefits of their
inventions and obviously they all do the
work you know they would do it if they
got no money as you're saying it's the
it's I call it the best job in the world
and you can prove it's the best job in
the world to be a university professor
or Pluto because it's the only job that
Neil Armstrong would accept after he
walked on the surface of the Moon he
became the professor of engineering so
we get to do what Armstrong uh wanted to
do but in all seriousness
um some of my colleagues have proposed
things such as you know we physicists
collectively not me you know invented
the transistor you know the laser the uh
internet uh you know the the at least
the you know some of the hypertext
protocols that CERN uh these are huge um
Capital uh uh you know kind of providing
Revenue providing uh things as Faraday
once said you know when he was asked
what's the use of electricity he said I
don't know but someday he'll tax it to
the king uh uh but but I wonder if we
know is there you know is there any
thought about let's say we you know one
of my colleagues thinks oh you should
tax every email you know a thousandth of
a cent in order to pay for physics
research you know just thinking again
very parochially is there you know do
people study this this would be a very
expensive experiment perhaps but in
other words how do we you know provide
for the future of the field of physics
um by we can't go after the fact that
you know give us money because we
invented the transistor is there
anything we can do in the future to
ensure you you know the Financial
Security not personal security and
myself or Michael yeah so I'm going to
kind of make a little bit of a sense of
that between the the personal yeah
security and the security of the the
field the because in terms of the
personal security no what I see in
economics now there's a lot more people
going into the into the tech working for
the tech companies they they kind of
they have realized that kind of like
computer scientists and statisticious
economists can actually contribute a lot
there and so
there are some some of the phds go into
that uh in into those companies and they
they make a lot of money they make that
some sort of some of my colleagues have
have done that on a temporary basis how
have gone permanently and if they do
that permanently they often end up
making four five times as much as they
they're making economics but in the end
very few
choose to do that because the academic
jobs just have incredible perks as well
in terms of doing what uh what what you
want to do so I don't know
so in that sense I don't don't and you
know here around in Silicon Valley I
kind of talk to some of the financial
capitalists and the entrepreneurs and
what I think what they're doing is
really interesting
but it also it takes skills that I don't
necessarily have and I think some of the
things even though I could well see that
they would
end up being very successful I wouldn't
find very interesting kind of to to be
doing and so I I would not want to I
said I made my choice here and I'm right
I'm incredibly happy doing what I'm
doing
that's it for the government for society
as a whole we need to make sure that we
keep the people going into these uh
these fields and we need to make sure we
fund them them well enough and we need
to kind of realize and expose some of
the work people have done even though
they may have looked x-anti like it
wasn't going to be particularly useful
turned out to be incredibly lucrative
for for society and we need to make sure
that those those inventions uh keep uh
keep coming yeah so finding some better
ways of
financing these things without nickel
and diming it's uh the the way it gets
done at the moment that that clearly
would be the
yeah good that makes sense yeah sorry to
interrupt yeah no and I I you know I
think there
used to be that some of the the
companies had had bigger research Labs
uh
sort of both hair of course with the
bowel laughs in in Holland the Philips
electronics company
but it was for a long time the biggest
company in Holland they had a big
physics lab kind of with the the very
distinguished physicists uh were working
and they they they as a company kind of
took a lot of their social
responsibility they they funded
all their employees kids kind of going
to college and stuff I got the funding
from uh from them when I was a
undergraduate so you would you would
like to see some of the tech companies
taking some of of their responsibility
as well in terms of of funding the PHD
programs that they take that they take a
lot of students from if you know it's
one thing for the government to pay for
their PHD programs if these students all
go back into public education but if if
they go to the private sector then maybe
the the companies should pay a little
bigger share of uh of the cost there so
I think we do need to think about how to
uh
to change the funding there
but so in this case kind of with with
this having the the lottery
gave us a very incredible way of of
figuring out what the effect of the the
and and Camus now it can still turn out
to be fairly complicated if you just
look at the winners and loser samples
these are actually quite different
because there was not because the
lottery was was not random it was just
there was there people would buy
different amounts of lottery tickets
people that would was differential
non-response uh because people didn't
necessarily answer our survey but in the
end we ended up with with
kind of both with credible the estimates
and we ended up with there any kind of
the
we ended up with estimates
that were credible we could demonstrate
that they were incredible kind of by
looking at how much these differences
were prior to winning and that these
statistical methods kind of eliminated
any difference uh between losers and
winners prior to uh to the time they
they won the the lottery so here this
this was again something that would
really satisfy Lima's concerns that
these were estimates that uh that you
could take to the bank and that you
could uh they were credible in a purely
you know efficient market wouldn't there
be some influence say on the expected
future value of money and that you know
in a low interest rate environment it
might be perceived by you know obviously
a knowledgeable person that it's it's
better to take a lump sum and you know
avoid inflationary concerns or or did is
anything in macroeconomically yeah a
principle that's that's uh that's yeah
absolutely right um and in fact there's
a market that kind of solves that
because if you win this this guaranteed
stream of income you can actually go to
the bank and ask for a lump sum and they
will discount it for you and practice
and I sort of Behavioral economics thing
what people get initially they sort of
tend to stick with that rather than go
through the trouble and and changing
that so a lot of people just stuck with
the 20 years payment system because that
was what they were offered by the the
lottery and they didn't want to have to
think through and worry about getting
taken advantage of by the bank by not
getting uh getting enough or getting the
or not trusting the the bank there they
clearly did trust the lottery at that uh
that point so in practice there's
actually you know this may not mimic
perfectly
uh Universal basic income but it's much
better than just what and that's kind of
essentially what the economists have
done before I said comparing people with
Rich with high earning spouses and
people with low earning spouses it's
sort of clear that
that the selection of spouses is not not
random uh either and that that variation
is not uh not particularly credible
yeah that was uh that was fascinating
yeah thanks thanks yeah it's great to uh
they have such a thorough and uh and and
delightful wide-ranging conversation I
wonder where you've been so generous
with your with your time and as you
economists say time is money
um but uh I wonder if you wouldn't mind
answering these four final questions
that I call my Fantastic Four questions
foreign
okay well they all involve some way
Legacy or you know advice to your former
self and most of my audience is Young a
lot of males listen to my audience so
yeah uh you can um kind of interpret
that as you like but but a lot of them
really do reply uh quite well to you
know advice and how to overcome the
challenges that you certainly have had
to deal with and and I think the first
thing I'll start with
is um as I said you know it's right
before my birthday right after your
birthday and in the Hebrew tradition
that I partake of there's a a notion
that the righteous lived to be 120 years
old so that's the age Moses lived to uh
and the uh and the uh stories of the Old
Testament
um and at that time he gave uh he gave
an invocation uh kind of uh that's what
the last book of the Bible is about
sorry to give a Bible lecture if you
already know this but the final book
called Deuteronomy in English or
davarium in Hebrew it's basically one
long will he's giving like a will not of
monetary will
um and he wouldn't get into the promised
land and not all of us get into the
promised land but he gave a ethical will
and it was kind of advice
and then uh from the the sort of wisdom
that he had acquired over his 120 years
I want to ask you when you reach the
biblical age of 120 uh what sorts of
wisdom would you want to give not just
to your biological children that you're
so devote to but to your ideological
children which there are many around the
world
[Music]
yes because I I realize I'm now almost
halfway so I just said that midlife it's
time for you to get a Corvette a red
Corvette and have a midlife yeah so you
know these are great questions because
I'm very uh reluctant to answer that
um but so
I think it's about one thing it's about
the the importance of of listening and
because now I've done a lot of talking
the last hour but you know against it
I'm I'm much more comfortable I kind of
I learned much more from from listening
and
then kind of pondering what I heard and
and read that I was
there talking to a politician that's
politician the other day because yeah
was an academic prior to being a
politician and he said at some point he
said something that that struck me that
resonated with me they said well a lot
of the politicians he talked to he was
he was admiring how confident they were
in their opinions and that he had a hard
time ever getting them to question their
their opinions and their and listening
it was having a hard time getting them
to listen and kind of to actually think
about Alternatives and kind of think
about
really questioning whether they were
right in their opinions and what what
other what alternatives were and I I
really get a lot of the
joy out of out of reading out of
listening and then thinking yeah
reflecting on what I I
heard all right
and at some level I feel very lucky that
I grew up in a in a world where that
that may have been easier when I was
there was not there were not quite as
many distractions as uh as there are in
the
in the current environment uh
and so I the um I think a lot of it's
It's about the the importance of uh of
listening and kind of getting exposed to
different the
opinions yeah
to for the the part of my audience that
is doing phds or whether it's in
graduate school or that is uh in
academics
also now
I want to convert it's it's not easy
it's not it's hard
you're all doing what we're all doing
it's it's very hard
and it kind of may you know yeah on the
in your podcast you have a lot of
incredibly successful for people and
they may make it look like it it's all
easy
but even there for the for these people
are so successful there's kind of a lot
of times when things are very hard when
I was in graduate school at Brown in my
second year there was a time when I was
very
fed up with the the with graduate school
and I started applying for for
non-academic jobs
I said I remember at some point I was
applying for a position at the bank and
they were it was a bank in New York and
they were looking for someone who was
fluent in Dutch and had a masters in
economics and I thought you know it's
written I just finished my Master's part
of the program and I I was fluent in
Dutch it was fluent in English I thought
you know this is this is I'm gonna get
this job man it was a lot of money they
were paying a lot of money it all seemed
same good and they didn't even interview
me so and then I ended up being by force
basically staying in the in the graduate
program and because they worked out
that very well but yeah I was going to
say it's too bad you could have had a
good career yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of times when when these
these things they don't go
your way you get papers rejected that
it's that's that's kind of pain that was
painful early on in my career it's still
painful the first four papers I go back
after winning the the Nobel Prize we're
all rejections uh I said I'm not you
know I don't want to complain I've been
very fortunate in in the way my papers
have been handled over the years but at
least yeah it's it's very hard
for us it's very hard for for everybody
and I know that people should should not
underestimate how challenging it is kind
of from a mental perspective in the
these jobs and people should should you
know be aware that everybody else is
going through this as well as part of
the Imposter syndrome
but
right people will clearly belong exposed
have suffered from that greatly
mentioned the conversation with your
Dutch politician friend it reminds me of
a quote from the Nobel Laureate Lev
Landau who won the year before you were
born and uh he used to say about
cosmologists my profession used to say
cosmologists are often in error but
never in doubt uh so uh that's kind of
one of the blind spots we have to guard
against okay the second of my Fantastic
Four questions uh is a quote from our
revolves around uh the quote from Sir
Arthur C Clarke that we opened the
podcast with which is any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic I want to ask you not
necessarily in your career but it could
be what kind of magical ideas
um have you encountered that you would
feel worthy of of you know kind of
having sort of a Swagger about uh as a
species uh from economics or any idea
you know for billions of years from now
when aliens find the Earth what kind of
things should Humanity in your field
your work even or completely you know
remote from your word chess or something
what could be the most uh the biggest
magical accomplishment of people yeah
you know that's that's uh that was
probably the trickiest from these four
questions uh I'd say the I was reminding
the fact we to be moved into a house on
Stanford campus about nine years ago
until we there I I had the the brilliant
idea of having the kids make a time
capsule to put in the walls because we
kind of did a major renovation there and
so we were going to open it 30 years so
about 21 years from now and so the kids
kind of all wrote some stuff uh my wife
and I did my parents did
and I now kind of thinking back at least
on what I wrote myself I didn't know
what anybody else really it's sort of
pretty disappointing to see how little
there was actually that I thought is
still relevant now I thought you know we
you know this is at the time that we
were
that we're driving our kids to school
all the time I said I thought you know
10 years from now we're going to have
self-driving cars and it's going to make
it so much easier to to get the kids to
school and I would solve these traffic
problems and you know a very easy
prediction it seemed like we would no
longer have print newspapers because
that's so clear that that makes no sense
to go print these things out and bring
them to people so when we still have a
subscription to a print newspaper and it
just and then you know you get the
pandemic and it's just nobody saw that I
mean there was just never
on our radar screen that I didn't could
actually happen and it I remember kind
of
reading that in Japan's schoolwork
schools were closing down and it just
seemed unimaginable that we would get to
that point in the U.S that the kids
would not go to school yeah of course on
the other hand it sort of
it shows the incredible resilience where
we can actually you know we manage to
make that work in a lot of places and
we've actually learned a huge amount you
know and that it's not really fair it
was it worked very well in some places
and but other parts of the population
suffer greatly as a result but it wasn't
enormous amount yeah of uh of resilience
uh there at the same time kind of you
know when the internet came out it just
seemed such an incredible promise and
now there's been a lot of
disappointments yeah where it didn't
really work as a something to make
democracy stronger and to weaken
authoritarian museums it kind of really
seems like it's pretty much the opposite
uh yeah and so reinforces it yeah it's
just so hard to but you know it seemed
like this would allow everybody to to
consume information and and sort through
it themselves and it turns out actually
it doesn't really work that way and
someone I talked to the this guy was a
editor of some news organization he said
well
he told us
before when we had newspapers that were
where the business model was it was
coming from advertising
that affect the advertisers had a great
moderating effect on the content because
you know if you're Procter and Gamble
you don't want to have crazy stuff in
the newspapers that you that you
advertise in right and at some level you
know at the time that seemed like a bad
thing we don't want Procter and Gamble
to kind of you know sense of what what
we can read but maybe that it was sort
of a good thing to have have somewhere
some adoration where now anybody with
crazy ideas can kind of find a platform
to uh to do that and you know yeah so I
so I don't really know what the the
a big idea sort of you know personally
kind of I did did kind of find
some of the ways of thinking about
causality that I was exposed to early on
in my career I kind of find that just
that was eye-opening for me
and then it's the some of the the work
to and the kind of just the life kind of
of Timber was very inspiring to me but
I'm not quite sure what I would want to
put on a monolith that's right well uh
we can move it to a uh to another uh
quote famous saying from Sir Arthur C
clarkes to say when an elderly but uh
distinguished scientist states that
something is possible they are almost
certainly right but when they say
something is impossible they are
probably wrong now I'm not calling you
elderly
we are a scientists there are uh you are
economic scientist and have a great deal
of uh Insight I want to ask you are
there things that you've changed your
mind upon or maybe a sea change in your
field that wasn't really something you
anticipated that you know uh in in
retrospect maybe could have been more
obvious or maybe maybe even something
you've completely changed your mind upon
not saying you're wrong about but you
had a turn of events hard about
[Music]
yeah so
um
I'm going to say two things here I said
one is there you know so so now I'm I'm
editor of one of the economics you want
to say I kind of read a lot of paper
that I try to kind of think about
whether
I've tried to keep a very open mind
about things where people are suggesting
things that are way out of the box and
so I had this paper a while ago where
someone said well you know all of
economics
sort of builds these models where we
discount the future a little bit we
don't put as much value on the future as
we we put on uh on today
I think they're saying well that was all
wrong we should we should discount the
future much more we shouldn't really
care about the the future like kind of
you may say well actually we should care
much more about the future now we're
going to be there a long time right yeah
we we've made it you know we've made a
mess of some things we should we should
value the future very highly but so this
guy said no no no you guys got it all
wrong you're you're putting too much
value on the future we should you know
pollute away climate change no worries
and his his argument was and this gets
more to your neck of the woods he said
well you know there's some chance we're
gonna figure out how to do time travel
and once we figure that out we're just
going to come back and clean up the the
present and so the fact that we've been
making mess of it now that's kind of
concerned we should just get a lot of
money to the physicists and they figure
out time travel and then we solve it all
yes I endorse that yes I said you know
the
this is you know this is not really for
for the general I run and you may need
to send it somewhere else
and in fact so I'm gonna gonna reject
this paper but it's really a win-win
thing because either I'm right and it
was the right decision or if I'm wrong
that's no problem either then I'm just
gonna go back and Expo come back in the
future expose publish the paper anyway
and then I look like genius
sir sir Roger Penrose uh tells a story
about how one day um Stephen Hawking was
around Cambridge and he and he put up a
desk and on the desk it said welcome
Time Travelers and Penrose and
everybody's what are you doing and then
the next day he published in the student
newspaper an advertisement for time
travelers to come and visit them
yesterday uh and so he was thinking he
could disprove
uh any any attributes any possibility of
time travel uh okay uh cleito you've
been you've been so generous um last
question now we're going to go backwards
in time maybe a time travel is really
applicable here uh and this is the uh
famous quote I use
um from Arthur Clark that says the only
way of distinguishing the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them into the impossible and that's the
name of the podcast I want to ask you
um what mysterious aspect of life maybe
perplexed you as a 20 or 30 year old man
that you'd give advice to your former
self about now to give you the courage
to do as you've done to go into the
impossible advice to your former self
[Music]
IE
yeah I sort of looking back at my career
I felt early on I wasn't very good at
picking good questions and I I think it
also also wasn't really very good at
talking to other people
about that I said no but but where I was
very lucky it was kind of connecting
with with people like angris and Ruben
early on who at the time to me felt like
they were much more confident like you
know this you know this is a stupid
question don't don't work on on these
things
but sort of trying to figure out
when it when a question is
it's worth spending a lot of of time on
kind of the ones I was kind of motivated
to to look at a particular question then
it kind of was just like playing chess
it didn't really matter that at some
level it was a where it was relevant or
irrelevant or not it once it engaged me
it was very easy for me to just get deep
into that and I nah I do feel that a
couple of times
in my career I kind of
ended up with a question I where I would
feel that there's something here I don't
understand but I feel deep down that
there is a solution that there is some
insight that is there's some better
understanding and I want to I want to
get to that place and kind of the and a
couple of times that that did work out
where at some point I really felt okay
this here now I know something that I
really didn't know before and that you
know
I don't think kind of in this field
people know that it doesn't mean it's
necessarily an important thing but I
really
felt a couple of times and like wow now
I've I've learned something that this is
sort of what what I'm I'm doing this for
and so I I kind of
suggest to my for myself to kind of be
more confident there in kind of trusting
trusting your interest because it's very
hard because you do make mistakes you
end up working on the on the wrong
things but again in combination with the
listening kind of just be willing
to spend time thinking hard about the
problems and and trusting that there's
trusting your intuition that there's
some solution there because developing
that intuition has been a long process
but I I've no
I feel I suppose earlier I was actually
better at that then I realized that at
the time wow yeah that's the uh that's
the message I think that's so important
for my audience to hear as I said many
people will will listen to this
um thousands and thousands and it's been
such a great treat to talk to you and
for you to share so much of your time
and uh from the land where the telescope
was invented uh I was afraid that you
might use another Dutch saying on me
which is
that
I thought you might you might say that
about me no no this is this is great it
was it was a very pleasant conversation
great to see you yeah wonderful it's so
nice to talk to you I hope we get to see
each other again
um my fellow man medalist and I wish you
great success and uh and and many many
uh checkmates to come if you do get some
time to play some chess uh that would be
lovely thank you so much for for joining
us tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Music]